Hello, welcome to another
episode of Banger Week,
Boom Week, whatever it's called.
I'm Gavin.
This is #DanTheMan.
He's having a whale of a time.
Look at him.
Excellent.
This week.
And I've got
remnants of all the other days,
like there's orange juice and milk.
Paint.
Dick guy.
All right, Lego!
Yeah.
Childhood.
Absolutely .
Let's build a house.
Hang on, yeah that's good.
Yeah.
Oh, Mega Blocks.
How much
Don't want that crap.
Mega blocks.
Alright, so my Lego skills
aren't really what they were.
Well, we had limited amounts of good Lego.
It's got mostly Mega Blocks so.
[Daniel] I reckon
Chewbacca's gonna get flying.
He's gonna get to the moon, oh.
You ready?
Yeah.
Yeah?
Whoo!
Ow!
Bloody hell!
Oh my goodness!
It blew a hole in the bottom of the thing.
What?
Ah man, these bangers do not piss about.
Bloody hell!
Did actually break the Lego up?
It blew out, do that again.
It blew out one of its nobbles!
It was a good one.
Well, we filmed that
2,500 frames a second,
which is a hundred times
slower than it happened.
It was so quick.
And it was still really
fast, it was pointless.
Yeah.
Let's just blow up the
whole thing of Lego,
I'm annoyed now.
Goodness me!
What a mess
What have we done?
Look at this crap.
How am I gonna clean this up?
There's gonna be Lego in
this grass for generations.
It's gonna be known as Lego gardens.
Tony Robinson's gonna be a
one day picking it all up.
The Time Team.
Well I feel, ooh, still
some Lego in the air.
I feel much happier now that the Lego
actually went everywhere
and we could see it.
Yeah, it was good.
All right, there's another video for you.
Got another one tomorrow?
Check back tomorrow.
I'm Gavin Free.
You're Daniel Gruchy on Twitter.
Give it a follow.
Yeah, tomorrow we blow up the world.
The world.
No, seriously.